hello i'm every politician in washington  running the country is hard enough but  explaining myself to voters that's  impossible most of them went to public  schools that's why i use grammarly  government edition it makes helpful  suggestions to all my messages so you  mouth-breathing sheep see things the way  i want you to  oh that's a good idea  all i have to do is set the party slider  and choose whether i want to appeal to  the country or my base grammarly does  the rest helping me energize support or  manufacture outrage though honestly  what's the difference grammarly turns  difficult policy positions into clear  unassailable sound bites and changes  messy unpalatable issues into confusing  but easy to swallow misdirection you may  be thinking motors aren't that dumb well  we wouldn't do this if it wasn't working  grammarly government edition helping  washington shovel all that [ __ ] you  people keep eating  i can't say spazz anymore  you